Donald Trump like so many candidates
talks about the need to get tough on
terror to what your works okay folks I
would bring back waterboarding and I'd
bring back a hell of a lot worse than
waterboarding it's a common theme in
culture these days Hollywood productions
like 24 zero dark thirty helped set off
a fondness for stories about getting
even at the bad guys one fingernail at a
time the post 911 image of torture
replaced the burns and beatings of the
old days with psychological techniques
like sleep deprivation mock executions
and threats to family members it seems
kind of like an improvement right but
researchers who compared physical and
psychological torture have found that in
the end the effect on the victim is
largely the same as the UN Special
Rapporteur on torture puts it a common
effect is the disintegration of the
personality the point of torture in an
interrogation is to regress the victim
to a place where he or she loses all
hope of control or freedom and really
can't do anything else but comply and
whether you hurt someone or just
threaten to hurt them they eventually
wind up in that place maybe that sounds
like the kind of get tough tactic that
we need to be deploying certainly Trump
seems to feel that way but here is the
real horror of it in 2006 a national
intelligence research group study the
effects of interrogation and coercion it
argued that pain or threats of pain have
no proven effect on getting truthful
information out of anyone but it does
have lasting effects on the person
tortured and the American Psychological
Association a longtime partner of the US
military has backed away from that
partnership over ethical differences
when it comes to interrogation in fact
the only way anyone has ever found
reliably get anything out of anyone is
to gain that person's trust and
affection over time and the truly ugly
work of budding up to someone we might
otherwise consider an enemy well that
method does not make for good stump
speeches I guess